[Applaus]
[Musik]
hollywood ist das wohl älteste
stadtviertel der welt ja das hast du
richtig ich habe gerade stadtviertel
gesagt denn hollywood ist keine
selbständige stadt ja noch nicht mal
eine eigenständige gemeinde hollywood
ist lediglich ein stadtteil von los
angeles und in diesem stadtteil leben
auf einer fläche von etwa 9
quadratkilometern gerade mal knapp
90.000 menschen
[Musik]
und dennoch konzentriert sich auf diesem
fleckchen erde ein großteil der
weltweiten filmindustrie
manche von euch mögen hier ist natürlich
einwenden kommt schon mag das ist nicht
wahr das indische bollywood produziert
pro jahr weitaus mehr filme als oliver
stone liebe es heute von visual politik
ihr habt recht aber wohl in indien mehr
filme als in jedem anderen land der welt
gedreht werden ist der daraus erzielte
umsatz im vergleich zur hollywood
lächerlich klein würde ich einfach mal
selbst wie viele indische filme hast du
lässt es ja geguckt von einigen
ausnahmen abgesehen werden
bollywood-filme hauptsächlich für den
heimischen markt in indien gedreht und
das gleiche gilt für nigeria denn
nigeria ist der zweitgrößte film
produzent der welt aber ich bin mir
sicher dass kaum einer von euch jemals
im leben einen nigerianischen film
gesehen
aus wirtschaftlicher sicht ist also
hollywood zweifelsohne die
welthauptstadt des films jetzt fragt ihr
euch eventuell warum reden wir hier bei
visual politik überhaupt über kino was
hat das mit politik zu tun nun wie ihr
gleich sehen werden eine ganze menge
[Musik]
wenn die tatsache dass ein großteil der
geldströme aus den filmeinnahmen gerade
nach hollywood fließt hat politische
gründe denn warum eigentlich gerade los
angeles und nicht new york oder zb
london gut viele von euch denn
vielleicht kalifornien sei schon immer
ein wichtiger staat innerhalb der usa
gewesen mit innovativen unternehmen
angesehenen universitäten und myriaden
von weltklasse promis die dort überall
anzutreffen sind die wahrheit ist aber
eine ganz andere
denn zu beginn des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts hatte ln und weniger als
100.000 einwohner war also kleiner ist
zum beispiel cottbus die ersten großen
filmproduzenten lebten noch alle auf der
anderen seite des landes in new york
chicago oder baltimore
die frage die sich hier stellt ist also
warum gehen sie ausgerechnet nach los
angeles was hat hollywood das manhattan
nicht hat und die allerwichtigste frage
was hat einwanderungen damit zu tun
heute werden wir all diese fragen
beantworten aber vorher wollen wir einen
blick zurück in die geschichte werfen
kunst von und für migranten okay lasst
uns ganz an den anfang gehen die erste
frage lautet also wer hat überhaupt den
film erfunden die gebrüder lemieux nun
nicht ganz was die gebrüder linie
erfanden war das system zur projektion
von filmen auf eine große leinwand
bereits um das jahr 1890 aber hatte die
firma von thomas alva edison ein system
zur aufnahme und wiedergabe und kurzfilm
entwickelt das kind es coop das war
eigentlich so was wie ein dieb show
münzautomat in dem man sich nach
geldeinwurf durch ein guckloch kurz
filme anschauen konnte
erst jahre später wurde dieses system so
weiterentwickelt dass diese kurzfilme
auch auf eine große leinwand projiziert
werden konnten der große unterschied
zwischen edison und den gebrüdern mehr
war aber das dem amerikanischen
geschäftsmann sehr sehr früh klar war
dass man mit filmen großes geld
verdienen konnte alles was ich lieg
verkauft will ich nicht erfinden
verkaufserfolg ist ein beweis für
nützlichkeit und nützlichkeit ist erfolg
thomas aber ellison während also die
gebrüder lemaire ihre erfindung auf
wissenschaftlichen messen präsentierten
machte er diesen bereits hätten sieht
sein geschäft bestand dabei darin die
kinder dass coop automaten zu verkaufen
eine lizenzgebühr für ihre nutzung zu
erheben und all diese mini kinos mit
vielen vielen filmen zu beliefern in nur
zwei jahrzehnten drehte edison mehr als
1200 filme
ihr fragt euch jetzt vielleicht was das
denn für filme waren die erde so nah
produzieren ließ nun so verrückt es auch
klingen mag viele diese erste firma in
der geschichte der menschheit handelt
einfach davon wie sich frauen entkleiden
komisch nicht wahr
bald jedoch entwickelte sich eine noch
viel größere zahl von geschäftsmodellen
rund um die filmvorführung im laufe
weniger jahre erlebt städte wie new york
oder chicago eine regelrechte flut von
kinos den sogenannten nickelodeon
diese boten viel vergnügen zu viel
günstigeren preis als jedes theater und
da es sich ausschließlich um stumpfe
handelte brauchte man noch nicht mal ein
wort englisch zu verstehen um sie voll
genießen zu können
und das bedeutet vor allem dass filme zu
der perfekten unterhaltung für all die
vielen einwanderer ins land der
unbegrenzten möglichkeiten wurden wir
befinden uns nun bereits im jahre 1900
in frankreich und interessanterweise
dänemark gab es bereits großes
filmproduktionsfirmen in keinem anderen
land aber gab es ein größeres publikum
als in den usa
[Musik]
thomas alber l sind war jedoch nicht in
der lage alle möglichkeiten hinter
dieser erfindung zu erkennen letzten
endes war edison ein arroganter
angelsächsischer protestant und
verachtete diese ganze migranten scharf
natürlich verdient er gerne gutes geld
mit ihm aber er sah keinen grund in die
qualität seine produktion für diese in
seinen augen kulturlose zielgruppe zu
investieren
schließlich hatte sich seine firma auch
das monopol für die produktion und den
vertrieb aller filme gesichert alle
diese nickelodeon verpflichtet nicht nur
kantine man dieses firma abzuführen
sondern eben auch alle seiner stelle
automatisch abzukaufen ohne jegliche
auswahlmöglichkeit in bezug auf reisen
filmtitel oder inhalte
niemand ging nämlich davon aus dass
polnische deutsche italienische oder
ungarischer einwanderer überhaupt
irgendwelche details in den filmen
wahrzunehmen in der lage sind
[Musik]
doch dann kam jener mann dessen bild
erst sehen könnt
das ist karl ende aus dem
oberschwäbischen laupheim biberach
lämmle war ein deutsch jüdischer
einwanderer und arbeitete zunächst als
geschäftsführer einer textilfirma dort
experimentierte er mit auffälligen
werbeaktionen und entwickelte neue werbe
techniken dies sehr erfolgreich warum
1906 machte er sich in chicagos
selbstständig und investierte sein sauer
verdientes geld in einem nickelodeon das
geschäftlich gut da levels sich durch
seinen marketing aus sehr gut von der
konkurrenz absetzen konnte aber als
schwabe war es bald leid so viel von
seinem sauer verdienten geld an edison
als zwangsgebühren abführen zu müssen
länder hat sich also mit anderen
nickelodeon besitzern zusammen sie alle
waren einwanderer die geschmack und
wünsche ihres publikums gut kannten sie
wussten dass mehr in filmen steckte als
nur billige witze und mädchen mit
knapper bekleidung selbe hatten das zeug
stars zu erschaffen sowie die broadway
theater
[Musik]
sie beschlossen also als sogenannte
independence trotz des monopols des
kartells namens motion picture pickles
company auch edison trust genannt
einfach auf eigene faust viel bessere
filme zu drehen level gründete das 1906
seinen ersten film verleih der mit
diesen filmen nur zwei jahren zum
größten filmverleih der usa heranwuchs
denn diese kino pioniere waren die
ersten welche die namen der schauspieler
auf den plakaten und dem abspann
aufhörten auf diese weise waren viel
mehr gute künstler bereit mit ihnen
zusammenzuarbeiten
diese filme erlangten unter den
einwanderern die aus der ganzen welt
kamen bald sehr große berühmt auf diese
filme erlangten unter den einwanderern
die aus der ganzen welt kam bald sehr
große berühmtheit aus diesem grund nahm
sie ihr unternehmen universe
und wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt hat
der schnelle erfolg dieses unternehmens
andere auch dazu inspiriert diesem
beispiel zu folgen ein jüdisch
ungarischer einwanderer namens adolf
super gründete zb zusammen mit der
anderen nickelodeon besitzern ein
weiteres studio namens paramount
pictures
aber moment mal irgendwas stimmt da
nicht haben wir euch nicht noch vor zwei
minuten von jenem rechtlich verbrieft
monopol auf produktion und vertrieb
aller filme erzählt welches der
knallharte geschäftsmann thomas alva
edison in seinen händen hält hat gerade
dieser umtriebige und mächtige
unternehmer mit all seinen patenten
politischen beziehungen und einer prall
gefüllten kriegskasse einfach so dabei
zugesehen wie all diese migranten
widerrechtlich massenweise filme drehen
und verleihen und damit auch noch einen
reibach machen ohne dass er auch nur
einen einzigen cent davon als
lizenzgebühr abbekommt weit gefehlt
dessen zog in den krieg gegen die
independence und in weniger als fünf
jahren wurden allein lämmle und seine
partner von nss armee von anwälten mit
mehr als 200 klagen überzogen
auch den rest der kleinen unabhängigen
studios bombardierte edison mit
permanenten gerichtsverfahren und viele
von ihnen mussten deswegen konkurs
anmelden
tja liebe freunde das waren schwere
zeiten für filmstudios aber eine goldene
ära für rechtsanwälte
so und als ob das nicht schon genug wäre
verfügte edison außerdem über genug
macht um all diesen kleinen clodius aus
new york und chicago exklusivverträge
aufzubringen wenn sie ihr dissens
technologie wollten dürften sie keine
filme seiner konkurrenten kaufen oder
ausleihen
und in genau diesem moment stellte sich
unser freund carl laemmle eine weitere
frage warum sollte ich an der ostküste
bleiben hätte sondern war ein mächtiger
mann aber seine macht reicht nicht
überall hin es gab einen weit entfernten
ort an dem er das sagen nicht hatte und
dieser ort oder kalifornien
die geburtsstunde einer industrie wir
schreiben jetzt das jahr 1915
kalifornien war jener ideale ort an dem
man einfach sein musste tausende von
jungen einwanderern das perfekte
publikum filme würden jedes jahr neu
eintreffenden häuser und grundstücke
waren billiger als anderswo in amerika
und als ob das noch nicht genug wäre war
das wetter einfach fantastisch
new york regnete es fast jeden zweiten
tag wenn man also filme drehen wollte
musste man über ein überdachtes studio
verfügen und tausende von dollars für
beleuchtung ausgeben ganz anders in
kalifornien zu jeder jahreszeit herrscht
sollen scheiden man kann draußen drehen
waren manley deshalb zogen all die
großen studios aus new york und chicago
in einem viertel am rande von los
angeles ein kleiner vorort mit wenig
mehr als damals 500 einwohnern dieser
vor ort war hollywood das aber ist noch
lange nicht das ende unserer geschichte
wir haben euch ja noch keine antwort auf
die frage von anfang dieses videos
gegeben
wie kam es dazu dass die kalifornische
filmindustrie das publikum der ganzen
welt erobern konnte vergesst bitte nicht
das zur damaligen zeit die vereinigten
staaten von amerika noch nicht jene
supermacht waren so der sie dann später
werden sollten außerdem verfügten länder
wie frankreich und das erwähnte dänemark
bereits über eine gut geölte
filmindustrie also wie konnte hollywood
so schnell international erfolgreich
werden die antwort liegt im sogenannten
netzwerk effekt wenn sie ihre
sozialpolitik abonniert habt ihr sicher
schon worum es geht die studios in
hollywood versuchten die besten
investoren und profis aus der ganzen
welt anzulocken
[Musik]
dies erklärt auch warum dort bereits im
jahre 1915 die erste riesen produktion
der filmgeschichte verwirklicht werden
konnte
the birth of a nation dieser film
kostete die damals gigantische summe von
100.000 dollar übrigens handelt es sich
um einen äußerst kontroversen film da
der rassistischen ku-klux-klan dort im
grunde genommen als die guten
dargestellt wird aber das ist eine ganz
andere geschichte in hollywood wurden
nun also die teuersten und
professionellsten filme weltweit gedreht
jetzt kam aber noch ein weiterer dritter
faktor hinzu quasi der kickstart für den
einzigartigen weltweiten export erfolgt
dieser film die meisten menschen die in
hollywood arbeiten waren nämlich
einwanderer wie zb francisco elias
dieser spanier kam nach hollywood um
dort als produktionsassistent zu
arbeiten
bald merkte er jedoch dass er die titel
der filme leicht ins spanische
übersetzen konnte auf diese weise finger
an sie nach spanien und lateinamerika zu
exportieren andere einwanderer mit
anderen muttersprachen taten das gleiche
so entstand quasi über nacht eine sehr
effiziente übersetzungs und
exportindustrie und alle hollywood filme
konnten überall auf der welt verstanden
werden aber warte mal prozent ich weiß
welcher gedanke die ich jetzt
beschäftigt was ist passiert als die top
filme kamen nun eigentlich war das der
wendepunkt in der geschichte des
amerikanischen films
hier ist ein beispiel während der nazi
zeit investierte die deutsche regierung
riesige summen in die subventionierung
deutscher film studios und natürlich
versuchten diese firmen ihre firmen
andere länder zu exportieren wie zum
beispiel spanien spanien war unter der
diktatur von francisco franco ein enger
verbündeter des dritten reichs trotzdem
liefen in spanischen kinos nur wenige
deutsche finden wie so ein grund dafür
lag im technischen und logistischen
vorsprung hollywood denn deutsche
studios schicken ihre filme in deutscher
sprache nach spanien und hatten keine
besonders guten systeme zur
synchronisierung ihrer stelle
[Musik]
spanier mussten sich die filme also mit
deutscher tonspur und spanischen
untertiteln ansehen nicht besonders
prickelnd für die massen nicht wahr
ganz anders die hollywoodproduktion dank
modernster ist organisations technik und
eines fast unerschöpflichen tucson
talentierten einwanderern aus aller welt
die als übersetzer und synchronsprecher
arbeiten konnten waren geschwindigkeit
qualität und kosten das
synchronfassungen von hollywood filmen
weltweit unschlagbar zu all dem kommen
die unvergleichlichen talente von
regisseur john ford der aus irland oder
ernst lubitsch der aus deutschland kam
sie waren die ultimativen waffen
amerikas indigenen es jedes andere land
übertreffen konnte wenn es um die
filmindustrie
wir können also mit lauter und stolzer
stimme sagen
sein erfolg gründete hollywood vor allem
auf jene menschen die aus den ausland
kamen und es wuchs um so schneller dank
der tatsache dass diese filme wiederum
ins ausland verkauft wurden so und an
dieser stelle muss ich eine kleine
fussnote setzen denn du weisst du noch
nie etwas von john vor ort ernst
lubitsch oder karl engel gehört haben
solltest du dir selbst einen gefallen
und schau dir ein paar von deren willen
an zum beispiel falls der mann der
liberty valance erschoss lubitschs sein
oder nichtsein oder lemnis im westen
nichts neues
es handelt sich dabei um nichts
geringeres als die sixtinischen kapelle
der filmkunst dies ist ein kleiner tipp
von visual politik und vertrau mir du
wirst ihn zu schätzen wissen so aber
schon jetzt könnt ihr uns im
kommentarbereich eure eigenen
einschätzungen mitteilen
glaubt ihr dass es noch andere
entscheidende faktoren für den erfolg
hollywood kam und was ist danach
passiert wie hat hollywood die zensur
und piraterie überlegt falls ihr möchtet
dass ich euch darüber etwas erzähle
lasst es mich bitte in den kommentaren
wissen denn schließlich veröffentlichen
wir jede woche frische informative
videos für euch also vergesst bitte
nicht unserem kanal zu abonnieren und
auch auf das glücklichen zu drücken
damit ihr keines unser update verpasst
und wenn du der meinung bist dass der
dieses video etwas gebracht hat gibt uns
bitte auch einen daumen hoch was gut und
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]